BUKOLA AYODELE: Today we're
talking about cortex framework,
automatic capacity
recommendations,
and application observability.
I'm Bukola.
And welcome to
This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Google Cloud cortex
framework helps
you kick start time
to value to get up
and running quickly
with Google Cloud.
We're extending our
available content
to include predefined BigQuery
data marts and lookup reporting
templates focused
on enabling faster
time to insight for
common order to cache
and financial analytics.
Customers have told
us that by having
the various lines of business
data available within BigQuery,
it opens up new opportunities
to extend with other data sets
to gain new insights and
better optimize core business
processes.
Check out our blog for more.
BigQuery already offers
flexible pricing models
such as on demand
and flat rate pricing
for running queries to meet
the diverse needs of our users.
We're excited to make it even
easier for you to optimize
BigQuery usage with new BigQuery
slot recommendations powered
by active assist.
It's a part of Google
Cloud's AI ops solution
that uses data, intelligence,
and machine learning
to reduce Cloud complexity
and administrative toil.
When IT operators and
architects begin their journey
with Google Cloud, day
zero observability needs
tend to focus on
infrastructure and aim
to address questions
about resource
needs, a plan for scaling
and similar considerations.
Developers and
DevOps engineers also
make a plan for how to
get deep observability
into the performance of
third party and open source
applications running on
their Compute Engine VMs.
That's why we recently launched
a dedicated UI under monitoring
integrations that guides you to
the available integrations that
may be a good fit for
your fleet, automatically
installs relevant dashboards
to help you get value faster,
and shows you the integrations
that are live on your VMs.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see the full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.